The joe rogan experience.
I don't want to fuck this up,
but it looks like it says pop pop,
pop,
Hoopa pub.
Who Pot.
I'm probably fucking that up,
but this is how it's pronounced.
I know how to spell it.
You don't like that one guy that got arrested for murdering his wife?
Was that,
what was that guy?
That old guy.
Phil Spectrum.
Phil Spector.
Oh no,
that wasn't his wife.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
That's very funny,
actually.
Good.
That's strong.
Strong.
Remember that guy?
He would show up for court?
Yeah,
with these crazy wigs on check.
He's got a brother Kimbal Musk,
Elon Musk.
He's a super genius that exists in the Lotus position.
Floats in midair and some wheat silo somewhere in New Hampshire and they go
visit them a couple of times a month.
I wouldn't mind.
I would be like,
give me a free test every couple of days.
They probably got that dude in the bunker with Dick Cheney right now.
Kimbal Musk.
What does he say?
Yeah,
I want to know what Kimble does.
He teaches Kung Fu.
He's in those videos that I always post on Instagram.
He just imagine if his brother was just a a nut.
Oh look at him.
Handsome bastard drinking coffee.
Oh my age.
45 regional manager for blockbuster video.
He's from South Africa.
I forget which guy was,
we were having a good fucking time though.
That was before anybody knew who rampage was.
I misunderstood him cause he was going by the slug once again,
like 99 2000.
I had finished it,
Ucla where I first got my taste of Jujitsu was at Ucla.
And then I got,
I graduated and I went to teen punishment and I get on the mat and Fabiana you
was a coach there at the time.
Find out what the best arm bars in the duty Monday.
His arm bar was fine,
especially Farside side.
And so we,
um,
I got on the mat and I shake hands with this dude and I said,
hey,
my name's Jimmy.
And he goes,
I'm rampage.
And I thought I misunderstood him.
I was like,
he can't sit,
you know,
I was like,
is it Randall or something?
And I just misunderstood him.
And all I knew was I knew armbarring to foot locker at the time and he was so
big.
I was like,
I'm just gonna foot log him and,
and I,
I went fully straight full locks on them.
And again,
I'm like,
Oh my God,
I'm going him.
And then I got an arm bar on him and he lifted me up to the ceiling with one arm
just around at my ass just went boom,
dropped right on me.
And Fabiano comes running over mad like,
oh,
you're not supposed to do that.
And just start screaming at him.
And he walks off ramp.
He turns to me.
He goes,
that'd be cool,
right?
And I was like,
yeah,
we're fine,
man.
I'm a wrestler.
I,
you know,
no big deal.
I've been slammed before and that was it.
That time it meant Quinten man back then.
Ladies and gentlemen,
Jeff Novitsky.
How are you buddy?
What's up Joe?
Doing good.
I have to ask you,
do you mind the nickname the golden snitch?
So first thing I was going to bring up
this golden snitch bullshit.
I just want to say,
it's not my nickname.
It's Brennan jobs.
He came up with it 100% on his own.
He was going to ask you.
It's all good though.
It's good.
It's all good.
So a couple of funny stories about that.
So
when did you come up with this?
About a year ago at least.
So,
so people in the office started coming up to me saying,
hey,
golden snitch,
what the hell is that?
Doing a little research as she,
something about Harry Potter,
some character named there.
I'm like,
what the hell does this have to do with me?
So about a month ago,
somebody lets me know,
hey,
check out Wikipedia.
So for whatever reason there's a Jeff Novitsky Wikipedia page.
You go to that page now it says,
says,
actually my formal name,
Jeffrey John Novitsky,
Aka the golden snitch.
So last week Donna Marceline,
you know Donna,
um,
long,
15 year employee of the UFC now works with me and talk about her a little later.
It's a great asset to what we're doing.
She sends me a text,
she says,
check this out.
So she's got one of those Amazon Echos.
Um,
Alexa,
I think so.
She says Alexa,
who's Jeff Novitsky and Alexis names as Jeffery John Novitsky,
Aka the golden snitch.
So thanks a lot.
Shop.
Oh shove,
what have you done?
Just bdis locked in on me and I think this thing's going to kill me.
And so I'm thinking,
you know,
when I say I'm thinking,
I don't know if I'm thinking,
I'm just,
I just remembered what I,
what was kind of going through my head at the time.
I thought,
Oh fuck,
I'm gonna die.
And my protections right there,
like,
I'm going to die.
This is that since situation where I'm dead.
And they talk about it and he could have saved himself,
but his guns on the ground.
And I think that that was like,
go for the gun was my whole thing.
So I start to go for the gun.
Yonis would've been here as I remember it.
And so I start to go for the gun and realize,
fuck,
I don't have time to get to my gun and it's three feet away to that bears like
right there coming down on me so fast.
So I kind of do like a football juke move left,
right.
And then wheel around right.
Do like a spin with my back and they start running to the left.
And at that point Yonis it,
I,
I didn't know this at the time because I looked at some pictures afterwards kind
of piece everything together.
So your honest was sitting right next to me.
I think he got up to turn.
There were some trekking poles right here.
He grabbed a trekking pole.
So probably while I was joking,
he reached around and grabbed the trekking pole swings around,
hits the bear in the face.
She's so then the IC,
the bear running off.
Then I see someone going down the mountain with the bear.
I'm thinking he's got someone.
So I grabbed my pistol,
start going down the mountain yelling,
Oh I Guess I,
I will count off.
And everyone's like one,
one,
one.
And I'm like,
Oh shit,
who's missing?
Right.
And then Garrett pops up out of the bushes and his eye,
he's like wide eyed.
So Garrett,
Ak dirt,
dirt myth.
He's the one who was on top of the,
somehow he's on the barriers back.
So I think when the bear wheeled around you like hit him and he ends up on the
back.
So I saw just legs and bear going down the mountain.
I saw his legs on the back of the bear somehow.
Like maybe the bear had him in his job.
Yeah,
that's what I was thinking.
Well,
I mean who?
Who would think
like if that was in a movie,
you'd be like,
get the fuck outta here.
What was that anchorman where the guy's like,
you're riding the bear.
That's exactly like God.
Yes.
And then we just kind of circled up around the tree and the real scary part was
that bear.
So it was so thick.
You really couldn't see.
I mean,
you could see maybe as far as the wall from us,
which was that the tree feet.
Yeah.
And just real thick brush.
And you'd hear the bear charge in again,
and we only have the two pistols Yiannis and I and the,
the,
the wind was so strong,
there's no way we could use bear spray.
So we hear the bear charging in and me and Yanna like pistols out ready,
waiting for this thing to pop out at point blank range.
And then you would see in your were yelling,
hey,
and then that thing stops.
And then it would just,
it crash off and then it would charge in from the other direction.
She ain't gotta like circle around the tree the other way and did that,
I think three times.
That was just a nerd.
It's like a horror movie where it keeps coming in from different angles.
It was weird.
It was not a fun feeling.
You just felt so small.
Yeah.